دوغ تعلم أن
الرئيس ترامب سينزل على أنه
أسوأ رئيس في تاريخنا ، فهل سيكون الأمر
كله متعلقًا بالتمرد أو
ماذا سيكون أيضًا
الإرث هنا جيدًا أنه كان هناك
تمرد شعبوي في الولايات المتحدة
وحول العالم
كان هناك  حركة يمينية كان لدينا
واحدة في التسعينيات
مع وقت قصف مدينة أوكلاهوما
مع بيل كلينتون كان رئيسًا ، تم
القضاء عليه من قبل ترامب واستعادته ، كان
قادرًا على الفوز في عام 2016
على الرغم من خسارته بثلاثة ملايين
صوت ،
لذا فهو علامة النجمة  الرئيس هو هذا
العرض الغريب
أم أنه سيتذكره أكثر
من حيث
مثل شخصيات بينديكت أرنولد وجيفرسون ديفيس كهذه
ولكن ليس لديه أي فكرة عندما يكون لديك كل
تلك القوة التي كان يمتلكها ثم
تفقدها ثم كل  الدعاوى القضائية التي
ستُعرض عليه ، فهو في ورطة عميقة
ولن أتفاجأ إذا تمت
إزالة اسم ترامب في السنوات القادمة في
مبانيه في شيكاغو ومدينة نيويورك
لأنه سيكون كذلك  يُنظر إليه على أنه نوع من
خطاب الكراهية اسمه بالذات
وهذا هو مدى سوء الأمور بسبب
ما فعله في 6 كانون الثاني (يناير)
2021. نعم ، لست متأكدًا
في شيكاغو ، أعتقد أن بعضًا من مدينة نيويورك
فوق معظم مبانيه أو العديد منها
يجب أن أقول